und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend auf dem asiatischen
Kontinent gibt es derzeit einen
regelrechten gipfelmarathon und immer
mit dabei die USA China und Russland
höchst brisante weltpolitische treffen
also den Auftakt bildet der asian-gipfel
in Kambodscha dort traf heute
US-Präsident Joe Biden ein am Dienstag
geht es weiter mit dem G20-Gipfel in
Bali und Ende kommender Woche gibt es
dann auch noch den asigen pazifik-gipfel
in Bangkok Joe Biden wird wieder dabei
sein Wladimir Putin allerdings nicht der
reist zu keinem dieser große Ereignisse
an muss vermutlich allen Beteiligten
auch sehr recht ist vom Treffen heute in
Kambodscha berichtet Norman Odenthal
Abflug Ägypten wenn der Auftrag hieß nur
mal kurz die Welt retten dann war das
wohl über ambitioniert Joe Biden reist
weiter vom Klimagipfel zum asiengipfel
der US-Präsident hat dort keine Probleme
gelöst hier kommen neue dazu Ankunft
Kambodscha wenn der Auftrag heißt nur
mal kurz die Welt retten dann wird auch
das über ambitioniert sein die Sorgen
sind jedenfalls zahlreich das
Versprechen auf Linderung begrenzt und
trotzdem ist beides gipfelhopping eine
Strategie die einleuchtet
vor Ort zu sein das ist enorm wichtig in
der asiatischen Kultur die physische
Anwesenheit zählt selbst wenn man
überhaupt nicht sprechen würde aber man
ist dort trifft die anderen auf
Augenhöhe das ist wichtig in Asien das
hat man in den USA verstanden
ein Gipfel im Zeichen der Krisen Unruhe
Herde von Nordkorea bis Myanmar
überschattet das alles aber vom großen
Machtpoker der Rivalität zwischen den
USA und China erkennbar dass beiden hier
neue Allianzen schmieden will
das asianstaatenbündnis ist das
Herzstück meiner indopazifikstrategie
wir arbeiten gemeinsam im Gleichschritt
zusammen mit dem Mitgliedstaaten Asians
heute gehen wir dabei einen
entscheidenden Schritt eine neue Ära
beginnt mit unserer umfassenden
strategischen Partnerschaft
was beiden hier feiert hat China längst
schon vereinbart Washington sieht also
bestenfalls gleich im buhlen um die
Gunst der Asiaten ein offener Wettlauf
der durchaus sorgen auslöst mit dem was
dahinter steckt
die Botschaft die aus Südostasien
gesendet wird in die USA und nach China
lautet bitte stört unsere regionale
Zusammenarbeit nicht die stabilisiert
diese Region nicht tragt euren Konflikt
nicht bei uns aus wir sind nicht die
Bühne für euren Wettkampf eure
Konfrontation das ist die klare
Botschaft
beidens Suche nach Allianzen umfasst
auch die allgegenwärtige russlandfrage
noch ein Konflikt in dem die Asiaten
nicht gern hineingezogen werden zum
Gipfel haben Sie deshalb die
Außenminister der Ukraine und Russlands
eingeladen der Russe labroff führte
Gespräche etwa mit indonesien und
Vietnam aber die Option seinen
ukrainischen Kollegen hier zu treffen
zog er nicht
Minister lavroff hat sich nicht um ein
Treffen bemüht wie man das sonst auf
diplomatischer Bühne tut sollte das noch
geschehen werden wir die Möglichkeit
sorgfältig in Betracht ziehen
so weit kam es nicht keine Begegnung
keine Kollision am Abend erschienen alle
im landestypischen Zwirn zum Gala den er
auch der Russe auch der Amerikaner man
sah sich sprach aber nicht das mag in
der asiatischen Kultur zwar schon viel
wert sein aber es hat die Lage nicht
verbessert
der Twitter nutzt konnte in den letzten
Tagen wilde Dinge erleben immerhin bekam
man sehr viel zu lachen was etwas hinweg
tröstete über die Sorge das
Neu-Eigentümer Elon Musk das Netzwerk
ruinieren wird sein Versuch mit der
Verifizierung von Accounts Geld zu
verdienen ging jedenfalls gründlich
schief zur Erklärung bisher war ein
sogenannter blauer Haken ein Gütesiegel
dieser Account ist echt der dort
schreibt ist tatsächlich der
Bundeskanzler oder der Papst erkaufen
konnte man sich das nicht Elon Musk Boot
solche Verifizierungen nun aber für
monatlich 8 Dollar an mit irrwitzigen
folgen
vergleichsweise harmlos waren da
beispielsweise die klerikalen Dialoge
zwischen diversen Päpsten und Martin
Luther allesamt mit Echtheitszertifikat
inzwischen hat Mast zumindest diesen
Fehler eingesehen Jutta sonnewald über
das Chaos bei Twitter
so posiert Super Mario auf einem
angeblichen Nintendo Twitter Account
jesus hat beim Kurznachrichtendienst ein
blaues Häkchen was für ein verifiziertes
Abo steht und eine bei Kindern und
Jugendlichen beliebte Videoplattform
verspricht Sex alles Neue Fake-Accounts
bei Twitter was komisch wirkt ist in
Wirklichkeit Ausdruck dessen was gerade
bei Twitter los ist die Social Media
Plattform ist außer Rand und Band eine
Folge von masks Neuordnungen der Regeln
die er täglich wieder neu ordnet
seit seiner Übernahme bei Twitter noch
mehr Chaos verursacht ich denke das wird
sich widerlegen aber wir haben gerade
einen popcorn-moment die nächsten Monate
werden wir sicherlich noch weitere
verrückte Irrungen und Wirrungen von
Musk und Twitter erleben
Elon Musk scheint unberechenbar jeden
Tag erreicht er sich mit neuen oft
widersprüchlichen Aussagen und Tweets
Aufmerksamkeit eben noch warnt er die
twitter-belegschaft vor einer Insolvenz
im nächsten Moment prophezeit der Ihnen
eine blühende Zukunft die wunderbare
Ironie der Situation ist dass die Medien
die pausenlos über Twitter und mein
Versagen schreiben ein massives Wachstum
bei Twitter bewirken schreibt er die
Zahlen sprechen eine andere Sprache
Twitter verzeichnet enorme
Umsatzeinbrüche für den Kauf der Social
Media Plattform hat der Tech Milliardär
einen hohen Kredit aufgenommen Banken
zweifeln ob er die Zinsen von jährlich
über einer Milliarde Dollar noch stemmen
kann
die Banken die mask bei der Finanzierung
geholfen haben werden wahrscheinlich bis
zu einer Milliarde Dollar durch die
Schulden verlieren für die Banken ist
dieses Geschäft ein absolutes Desaster
große Werbekunden haben sich von Twitter
zurückgezogen weil Hetze rassistische
Beleidigungen und Fake-Accounts in der
letzten Woche rasant zugenommen haben
der Dienststelle ein enormes
Sicherheitsrisiko da warnt Peter satko
der Anfang des Jahres als
Sicherheitschef bei Twitter geschafft
wurde und als Whistleblower beim
US-Senat Beschwerde gegen seinen
früheren Arbeitgeber eingereicht hat
twitter-ingenieure hätten
uneingeschränkten Zugriff auf private
Daten der Nutzer so satko
Twitter mit einem Flugzeug vergleichen
man steigt ein und jeder Passagier und
auch das Kabinenpersonal haben Zugang
zum Cockpit das ist zu einfach denn so
kann jeder ob absichtlich oder nicht
eine Turbine ausschalten
gestern haben weitere Top-Manager
Twitter den Rücken gekehrt die beiden
Sicherheitschefs und der
datenschutzbeauf Worte das twitter-chaos
hat nun die us-verbraucherschutzbehörde
FTC auf den Plan gerufen sie warnt
sollte Elon Musk sich nicht an
Vereinbarungen zum Datenschutz und zur
Sicherheit halten drohen Twitter
milliardenstrafen Elon Musk scheint all
das wenig zu beunruhigen stattdessen
stellt er heute sarkastisch die
Scherzfrage twitter ist weniger lustig
lustiger oder ich lache mich darüber
kaputt
jetzt geht es erstmal bei dir weiter
Heinz mit den Entwicklungen in der
Ukraine herr Präsident selensky hat nach
der Rückeroberung der süd-ukrainischen
Gebietshauptstadt herson die Befreiung
weiterer Gebiete angekündigt die von
Russland besetzt sind selensky erklärte
russisches Militär habe vor dem Abzug
wichtige Teile der Infrastruktur
zerstört dazu gehörten
Kommunikationseinrichtungen Fernwärme
Wasser und Stromversorgung in Carson
wurden die ukrainischen Soldaten von der
Bevölkerung jubelnd empfangen
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat das brutale
Vorgehen der iranischen Regierung scharf
verurteilt in seinem Videopodcast zeigte
Scholz Worte allein reichten aber nicht
deshalb werde gehandelt er nannte unter
anderem Sanktionen der EU iranische
Drohungen wie es Scholz zurück ich habe
gehört Irans Außenminister drohe
Deutschland mit Konsequenzen für diese
Haltung und unser Vorgehen ich kann der
Führung in Teheran nur sagen was sind
sie für eine Regierung die auf die
eigenen Bürgerinnen und Bürger schießt
wer so handelt muss mit unserem
Widerstand rechnen
auch vier Tage nach den Zwischenwahlen
in den USA sind die künftigen
Mehrheitsverhältnisse im Parlament noch
offen im Rennen um die Senatssitze
liegen Demokraten und Republikaner mit
jeweils 49 sitzen aktuell gleich auf
nachdem jetzt aus Arizona der
demokratenmarkt Kelly als Sieger bekannt
gegeben wurde
zwei Sitze im Senat sind noch offen
holen die Demokraten mindestens einen
davon behalten Sie dort die knappe
Führung weil sie auch die Vorsitzende
stellen
in Lutzerath im am Braunkohletagebau
Garzweiler in Nordrhein-Westfalen haben
heute laut Polizei mehr als 1.000
Menschen demonstriert die Veranstalter
sprachen von über 2000 sie fordern den
Erhalt von lützerath und dass die Kohle
dort im Boden bleibt der Ort soll dem
Braunkohletagebau weichen zu der
Kundgebung hatte ein Bündnis aus
Umweltverbänden und klimapolitischen
Organisationen aufgerufen
China treibt weiter sein ehrgeiziges
Raumfahrtprogramm voran heute ist ein
Frachttransport zur gerade fertig
gestellten Raumstation tjengong zu
deutsch himmelspalast geflogen an Bord
sechs Tonnen Material und
Versorgungsgüter Ende November wird es
den ersten Besatzungswechsel geben dann
sollen drei Raumfahrer die aktuelle Crew
ablösen
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 4 7 12 14 21 47 Superzahl 6
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
die Wetteraussichten für morgen östlich
der Weser und am Ober- und Hochrhein
können sich Nebel und Hochnebel länger
halten sonst scheint die Sonne die
Temperatur steigt auf Werte von 10 bis
17 Grad bei Nebel bis 7 Grad am Montag
gibt es noch einmal viel Sonne nur im
Südwesten kann es Schauer geben ab
Dienstag nehmen Wolken und Regen von
besten herzu es bleibt mit 8 bis 15 Grad
aber weiterhin mild
auf den Tag vor 150 Jahren kam das
Unheil die
ostseesturmflut im november
1872 war so furchtbar dass bis heute
daran erinnert wird auf alten
Zeichnungen ist das Drama festgehalten
hier die Überflutung des holsteinischen
Dorfs Haffkrug in der Neustädter Bucht
es war eine spezielle Wetterlage die die
Katastrophe damals auslöste einen Orkan
der die Wasserstände auf Höhen trieb die
zuvor und danach in der Region nie
wieder gemessen wurden ein einzeleignis
doch meteorologen warnen das ist auch an
der ruhigeren Ostsee solche Fluten
künftig häufiger geben könnte bedingt
durch Klimawandel und
Meeresspiegelanstieg handmoselbach
eine Seite aus dem Kirchenbuch von
Prerow
ertrunken ertrunken ertrunken oder auch
Kinder sind ums Leben gekommen und
es war schon sehr dramatisch also Gregor
hat die meisten Toten hier zu beklagen
gehabt hier sind zehn Einwohner ums
Leben gekommen und dazu kam noch 12
Seeleute von zwei gestrandeten Schiffen
november 1872 tagelang drückt
stürmischer Wind aus Südwest Wasser aus
der Nordsee in die Ostsee dass ich vor
der Küste Finnlands staut bevor es
wieder abfließen kann dreht plötzlich
der Wind wird zum Orkan und treibt das
Hochwasser mit Macht gegen die deutschen
Küsten
271 Menschen starben 15.000 werden
obdachlos 133 Schiffe sinken René
Rohloff zeigt uns seinen Elternhaus
gebaut 1872 vom Ururgroßvater bezogen
nur wenige Monate vor der Katastrophe
Roloff lebt und arbeitet in diesem Haus
ist Tischlermeister in 6 Generation die
Sturmflut hat sich tief eingegraben
Gedächtnis seiner Familie es kam bei
Nacht es war eiskalt Orkan Schneetreiben
und das Wasser kam sehr sehr plötzlich
das stieg innerhalb von Minuten
zusehends an und man flüchtete in aller
Eile hier auf den Dachboden und sah dann
aus der Bodenluke Schiffe vorbei treiben
Gartenlauben viel in den
flutenfamilie Rohloff überlebt kann auch
ihr Haus retten Jürgen Jensen erforscht
die Folgen des Klimawandels für die
Ostsee eine Sturmflut wie 1872 würde
heute 200.000 Menschen treffen die
Schäden Milliarden schwer das für 150
Jahre keine größere Sturmflut hatten
ist ein Glücksfall insofern ist
eigentlich davon auszugehen dass im Zuge
des Klimawandels mit höheren
Wasserständen mit höheren mittleren
Wasserständen so etwas sich auch in der
Zukunft wieder darstellen wird die
Katastrophe gilt als Geburtsstunde des
modernen Küstenschutzes die Halbinsel
Fischland Darß Zingst heute vielfach
geschützt der Deich der Küstenwald die
bepflanzte Düne und vor dem Strand der
immer wieder aufgeschüttet wird die
Buhnen Experten rechne mit einem Anstieg
des ostsee-spiegels von etwa einem Meter
bis Ende des Jahrhunderts bereits jetzt
investiert Mecklenburg-Vorpommern rund
25 Millionen Euro jährlich in den Schutz
seiner Küsten ein Wettlauf mit der Zeit
Ausgang ungewiss wir werden die bebauten
Gebiete die ein Ortskern haben die
werden wir schützen aber wir werden
nicht jedes einzelgeheft schützen können
und wir werden uns auch daran gewöhnen
müssen aus bestimmten Gebieten uns
zurückzuziehen Freunde Roloff ist auch
Bürgermeister seines Heimatortes den
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel will er
gewinnen sie gehen davon aus dass Prerow
ihr Ort hier die nächsten 100 Jahre auch
überleben wird absolut länger als 100
Jahre mit überleben Pläne für das
nächste deichbauprojekt gibt es schon
ein ringdeich rund um Prerow seit 1872
stieg der mittlere Pegel musste übrigens
bereits um mehr als 20 cm
das war es von uns an diesem
Samstagabend weiter geht's mit dem
Aktuellen Sportstudio und danach so
gegen 0.25 gibt es die nächste heute
Express bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]